que la vocation agricole est maintenue
le morcellement du territoire peut
permettre à de plus petites entreprises
de se lancer en production et c'est
exactement ce qu'on souhaite dans un
village au Temiscamingue
[Musique]
au thème le producteur d'agneau Simon
gélina est maire de leur unville il
attend bientôt du 109 dans son village
on a un beau projet le municipalité pour
justement accueillir des nouveaux
projets agricoles avec des belles
petites terres pour qu'on peut offrir
aux gens
[Musique]
voici l'espace prévu pour installer les
nouveaux agriculteurs
une terre agricole que la municipalité
possédait depuis l'abandon de grands
projets industriels
[Musique]
de noblesse mais elle reste agricole le
but c'est pas de la nature on veut y
redonner encore plus sa couleur c'est ce
qu'on veut invite mais on veut qu'elle
soit encore plus verte dans une première
phase la municipalité offre quatre lots
de 25 ans soit 10 hectares chacun
Petite Terre à vendre à qui veut la
cultiver
dans le fond la chance aux gens de
pouvoir acquérir de l'agriculture avec
une petite superficie parce qu'on sait
bien que maintenant on s'est rendu
difficile de pouvoir acquérir un terrain
agricole
mais morceler cette terre en petite
superficie ne sait pas fait en criant
ciseaux
laurinville a d'abord encaissé deux
refus de la Commission de protection du
territoire agricole la CPTAQ
puis après 8 ans en 2021 le morcellement
a enfin été autorisé
pour moi j'ai commencé cette projet-là
en 2013 puis là
on suit le bébé c'est ça qu'on veut on
veut que le bébé il grandisse
pour la région l'offre des fêtes ni à
brides aubaine ni appris exorbitants
5000 dollars pour la parcelle une
condition l'acquéreur doit s'engager à
récolter des produits maraîchers en
régie biologique
le pouvoir savoir que leur cas de
voisins vont être biologique mais ça
c'est vraiment un plus et de regarder
aussi
autour de nous autour de cette projet-là
on a déjà des champs en production
biologiques parce que céréalier ici on a
un beau 6 700 heures autour qu'on a une
ferme céréalière qui est biologique
est-ce que tu crois que la grange va
faire de l'ombre à la maison premier
acheteur le couple Daniel Bourgault et
Kim Leroux on cherchait un open terre
pour plus une femme forestière puis
quand on a vu ce projet-là popé
on embarque puis on dépose quelque chose
puis on se pose les manifs
[Musique]
virage à 180 degrés pour ce directeur
des opérations d'une grande entreprise
forestière et cet enseignante
[Musique]
avec les
carre
de la permaculture ça c'est de notre
cliente
environ puis c'est ici qu'on veut
destiné la culture dans fruitier destiné
vraiment faire du cidre
encore quelques mois et l'espace sera
couvert de pommiers
[Musique]
on va tous protéger un peu
la préparation des sols est en
marcheulté la petite partie là-bas que
vous voyez changer de couleur on a
planté à l'automne des poids et avoine
pour enrichir le sol capteur d'azote
pour ne pas le temps de finir ce côté si
on a juste le pour essayer de contrer
contrôle un petit peu les plans les plus
envahissantes pour se préparer
tranquillement prochain étape de drainer
ce boutique
si le projet des
Burgos semble bien amorcé les loups
voisins ne se vendent pas vite après
presque un an il y en avait toujours
trois à offrir
les exigences de la municipalité au
départ ont fait fuir plusieurs candidats
un peu plus pointus maintenant on l'a
assoupli nos conditions d'admissibilité
un petit peu par exemple l'obligation de
vendre 5000 dollars de produits
agricoles la première année a été
abandonnée l'acquéreur a maintenant une
période de deux ans pour démarrer sa
production
[Musique]
ce qu'on exige c'est qu'on doit
constater une évolution indépard un
démarrage agricole sur leur lots parce
que bien sûr on veut pas qu'une personne
achète un lot et ça soit dessus et qui
qui ne fait rien avec le bus c'est
vraiment de l'offrir X ou accessible
pour l'agriculture c'est qu'on veut pas
que les gens le prennent seulement pour
acheter un terrain du déjà vu
[Musique]
le morcellement représente un danger
défritement du territoire agricole si
elle n'est pas en exploitation une
thermorcelée mène tout droit au dézonage
ici 90% du territoire est en zone
protégée la pression domiciliaire est
faible et la municipalité souhaite
l'arrivée de nouvelles familles la
réalité de bien des villages en
périphérie
les autres régions là
les téléphones les courriels que j'ai
reçu de la haute Gaspésie de plein
d'autres et merci où ils vivent la même
situation que nous qui sont éloignées
que j'aimerais ça capable de mettre la
gage à côté dans montagne puisse faire
un chemin pour accéder aux deux amateurs
jusqu'au rive être propriétaire leur
permet de mener des projets à plus long
terme comme bâtir une maison
à plusieurs reprises parce que on
découvrait
la clarté du soleil plus on dirait ok on
prébâtir la maison ici pas forcément on
pourrait la changer de place mais le
morcellement tel que mis en place alors
un vile ne convient pas à toutes les
régions
l'ancien sous ministre Michel St-Pierre
croient que le législateur aurait dû
aborder la question de la location à
long terme en France à peu près 3/4 sont
exploitées sur une base de location avec
des bons de 30 ans ce qu'on a pas ici
non mais ça
se crée aussi même elle est d'Orléans il
y a des fermes qui seraient certainement
ouverte à l'idée de louer à des jeunes
alors l'île d'Orléans un bel endroit un
beau petit laboratoire pour faire ça
par contre pour certains la location
n'est pas envisageable c'est le cas
danucarons en Estrie qui fait face à des
investissements majeurs pour démarrer
son élevage de bisons
la clôture des champs pour contenir le
troupeau par exemple
on investissement qui est autour de 250
000 pour la grandeur que je recherche
donc c'est un trop gros investissement
pour être capable de prendre une
location que ce soit de 5 ou 10 ans si
on met dehors après 5 ans puis que je
dois réinvestir c'est mon temps là sur
une autre clôture ailleurs c'est mon
modèle d'affaires qui ne tient pas
reste que pour certains le morcellement
des terres demeure une occasion
exceptionnelle
Laurent ville l'a compris elle est
d'ailleurs une des premières
municipalités à mettre en vente des
terres agricoles morcelées
à la maison les premiers arbres
fruitiers seront plantés ici d'une
journée à l'autre des poires des prunes
des cerises destinées aux voisinage
enfin vu que c'est sur le bord de la
route on s'est dit pourquoi pas utiliser
ce terrain-là pour faire de l'auto
cueillette alors on voudrait offrir à la
population du thémiska mangue l'occasion
de profiter de notre culture en les
invitant à accueillir eux-mêmes leurs
fruits
l'agro-thorus devient alors possible
pour le merglina si les quatre sont là
qui veulent créer un marché sur le bord
de la route ou de pouvoir vendre leurs
produits ça va être vraiment le fun mais
c'est un projet comme celui-là qui va
nous encre ici qui va nous le faire
permettre de passer notre retraite ici
puis nos vieux jours puis si on est
capable éventuellement donner quelque
chose à quelqu'un
[Musique]